le problème du réchauffement climatique
évidemment que ça nous préoccupe et au
plus haut point puisque quand on est en
prise directe avec la pousse naturelle
de l'herbe on se rend bien compte que
les sécheresses successives impactent
fortement le potentiel alimentaire pour
les troupeaux donc là aussi pour
recouper un peu avec la prédation quand
j'entends qu'il y a des évolutions dans
les mouvements de de transumance des
troupeaux des redescente d'estive plutôt
ou que c'est souhaitable par rapport
effectivement vous l'avez dit au fait
que les louves les louves apprennent les
petits à chasser euh vous comprenez bien
que on a plutôt tendance à monter plusut
tôt en estive et à redescendre plus tard
parce que quand on voit l'impact de la
sécheresse sur les zones de plaines et
la transumance c'est essentiellement ça
hein on va en montagne l'été quand il
n'y a plus de ressources en plein donc
c'est c'est extrêmement problématique et
pas toujours réalisable et en tout cas
économiquement parlant c'est c'est pas
compatible quoi parce qu'on se dit voilà
si on perd le le l'herbe enfin l'herbe
les les ressources alimentaires que l'on
trouve en montagne ben on va pas pouvoir
les remplacer en pleine donc derrière ça
suppose des achats de fourrage des
coûpts de production qui augmente et et
tout ça donc ça aussi c'est c'est
problématique mais le réchauffement
climatique en tout cas pour
l'élevage on n pas beaucoup de solutions
et et je dirais que autant on a on
essaie d'avoir des comment dire des
connaissances scientifiques sur tout ce
qui est prairie temporaire pousse pousse
de l'herbe que que que l' on s'aime
autant on a très peu de retour sur le
comportement des espaces naturels et la
résilience de ces espacesl au changement
climatique et on se rend compte quand
même que bon moi pour pour ne parler que
d'écosses que je connais
particulièrement bien sur lesécosses on
voit bien que l'impact de la de la
sécheresse et des canicules que l'on
subit
euh arrive que font que les parcours ne
se régénèent pas et ça c'est c'est un
problème vraiment qui nous préoccupe au
plus haut point et et on a très peu de
retours scientifiques très peu d'intérêt
sur le sujet